- I declare bankruptcy!
Sometimes I'll start a sentence
and I don't even know where it's going.
I just hope I find it along the way.
I'm not superstitious,
but I am a little 'stitious.
I love inside jokes.
I'd love to be a part of one someday.
I am Beyonce always.
It's never too early for ice cream, Jim.
I like waking up to the
smell of bacon, sue me.
Make friends first, make
sales second, make love third,
in no particular order.
(playful music)
You know what they say,
fool me once,
strike one,
but fool me twice,
strike three.
I understand nothing.
Swag,
stuff we all get.
There is no such thing
as an appropriate joke.
That's why it's a joke.
We're all homos, homo sapiens.
Would I rather be feared or loved?
Um, easy, both.
I want people to be afraid
of how much they love me.
Abraham Lincoln once said
that if you're a racist,
I will attack you with the North.
You don't know me.
You've just seen my penis.
Webster's Dictionary defines wedding
as the fusing of two
metals with a hot torch.
The worst thing about
prison was the dementors.
Where are the turtles?
I love my employees,
even though I hit one of you with my car.
I don't wanna do anything, I'm dying.
It's a good thing Russia
doesn't exist anymore.
I knew exactly what to do,
but in a much more real sense,
I had no idea what to do.
Now, you may look around
and see two groups here,
white collar, blue collar,
but I don't see it that way.
You know why not?
Because I am collar-blind.
It's Britney, bitch.
Nope, just poopin'.
You know how I be.
I have cause.
It is because I hate him.
Grief isn't wrong.
There is such a thing as good grief.
Just ask Charlie Brown.
Tell him to call me ASAP as possible.
Well, well, well,
how the turntables.
Just seems awfully mean,
but sometimes the ends justify the mean.
Crazy world, lotta smells.
Big butt, bigger heart.
It's a pimple, Phyllis.
Avril Lavigne gets them all the time
and she rocks harder
than anyone alive.
It was a weird day.
I accidentally cross-dressed.
Don't ever, for any reason,
do anything to anyone
for any reason, ever,
no matter what.
No matter where or who,
or who you are with,
or where you are going or,
or where you've been,
ever.
For any reason whatsoever.
I am running away from my responsibilities
and it feels good.
His last name is Christ.
He has the power of flight.
He can heal leopards.
And I know it's illegal in Pennsylvania,
but it's for charity
and I consider myself a great philanderer.
I feel like all my kids grew up
and then they married each other.
(playful music)
It's every parent's dream.
That's what she said.
(playful music)
- [Man] Hey, guys, we're
- [All] Pero Like!
- Did you know it's
Hispanic Heritage Month?
- No me diga!
- For more Latino content,
- Subscribe here.